you are watching cold fusion tv
hi welcome to another cold fusion video
general electric one of the largest and
well-known multinational conglomerates
from medicine and aviation to energy and
kitchen appliances
it's safe to say that they do a fair bit
but how did the company begin
and just how big is it and what about
the deeper story
are there any other lesser known secrets
that we should know about general
electric
let's begin and honestly you don't know
what you've been missing until you get
this wonderful ge combination
we didn't we didn't have this separate
freezer section with a separate door
and a freezing system all its own
general electric or ge
was founded by thomas edison in 1889
when he merged many businesses
into just one corporation he did this
with the help of jp morgan and anthony
drexel
as we all know edison did a lot of great
things but by at least
a few measures edison wasn't a nice guy
he cheated nikola tesla in the 1880s
and sought to destroy tesla's progress
by many desperate means
including the electrocution of local
pets but that's all coming up on this
channel a bit later and there's a story
for another day
so subscribe if you want to see that
anyway despite edison's misbehavior
in 1886 ge was one of the first 12
companies
listed on the newly formed dow jones
industrial average
after 120 years they're the only one of
the 12 original companies
still listed on the index in the early
1900s
the company was one of the first to
enter the new business of voice radio
broadcasting
out of which came radio corporation
america
or rca a massive company of the 20th
century there's nothing we want to watch
on tv tonight
but we're still going to watch something
great with our rca video disc player and
video discs
just flip a switch we're watching a
great movie
and you're watching us
also around this time ge was the company
that would introduce the first electric
toasters
and hot plates a mini revolution for
home cooking
in the 30s the company responded to the
great depression by introducing ge
consumer finance so customers could pay
for their new appliances
over time it was the 1930s and 40s that
saw
ge usher in innovations like the
fluorescent lamp and the first autopilot
for commercial applications
interestingly enough in the 1950s ge was
the first business
in the world to own a computer and they
were the largest user of computers
outside of the us government after this
ge started manufacturing their own
mainframe computers and even their own
operating system
alongside companies like ibm and
honeywell ge
was actually one of the major 8 computer
companies of the 1960s
this era came to an end in the 1970s
when they sold their computer division
to honeywell
throughout the 20th century ge expanded
into many fields
one of which was energy and in 2002 the
company acquired wind power assets from
enron when they went bankrupt
as it turns out enron wind was the only
surviving us manufacturer of large wind
turbines at the time
by the end of the 20th century and the
start of the 21st century
ge was a true global giant and a
household name
today general electric is now ranked
number 24 in the fortune 500
in terms of revenue let's take a look at
some aspects of its actual size
general electric has 305 000 employees
with a revenue of 146 billion and over
650 billion dollars worth of assets
that's more than the gdp of sweden or
norway
or two times the gdp of singapore
the company is also listed as number
nine on the forbes world's most valuable
brand list
okay so that's all very nice but how do
they make all of their money
well i'll tell you but before we get to
that i'm going to ask you something
what do you think is ge's biggest money
maker
that's a no-brainer it's energy right
well
no let's take a look at this three-year
chart of ge's revenue
as you can see their largest segment is
actually finance
at 31 this is anything from personal
loans and credit cards
to energy related financial services an
interesting fact
within the capital markets in terms of
market share
there are about half that of jp morgan
chase
bank of america or citigroup and that is
significant
because those three banks are actually
the result of a merger of 28 banks
since 1990 so they're no small feat to
measure up to
the next biggest segment for general
electric is power and water
at 18 this includes gas wind and steam
turbines
nuclear reactors solar power and
generators
next up at 14 is aviation so these are
things like aviation services and
systems
and commercial and military engines the
next segment at 12
is healthcare so this is mris ct
scanners
x-rays and surgical and molecular
imaging machines
ge takes out about 39 of the medical
equipment industry in terms of market
share
so what about oil and gas surprisingly
the oil and gas sector
only makes up 10 of ge's income
so aside from all of this ge also makes
some other things such as refrigerators
freezes electric and gas ranges cooktops
dishwashers
dryers microwaves and you get the idea
so we're going to change things a little
bit here as it turns out
it's not all roses for ge there were
certain times in their history
that they were not seen as one of the
golden geese of innovation
the problems lie within the details of
ge's activities that aren't conveniently
displayed or listed on their website
there was actually a time when the
people of the world came together and
rallied against general electric
let's hear the story
the year is 1984 and in the u.s ge
produced more parts to more major
nuclear weapons systems than any other
corporation they also promoted nuclear
weapons to the government
few people actually remember the
existing tie between the president at
the time
and general electric you see ronald
reagan was actually a spokesman for
general electric
before he became president for general
electric here is ronald reagan
good evening at general electric
progress is our most important product
kelly lualia founded a group called
corporate accountability international
for the sole reason of stopping ge from
producing nuclear weapons
that same year in 1984 kelley's group
organized an international grassroots
campaign including a 40 nationwide film
exposing the truth behind ge's corporate
image
general electric is in this business of
building weapons
for profit not for patriotism not for
the country not for the flag
but for profit the campaign also
included a boycott of all general
electric products
the kickoff of the project got off to a
strong start
but would it work in 1989
three years into the boycott and five
years into the overall campaign
ge spent four times more on brand
advertising to defend its brand image
that in the past four years combined the
fight
was on by 1990
4 million people in the united states
alone were boycotting ge
and the campaign activities had actually
spread across to canada and into western
europe
major retail stores replaced ge light
bulbs with those made by other companies
in april of 1993 after seven years of
boycotting
the people had finally won general
electric completed its move out of the
nuclear weapons business
stating that it was a business decision
the boycott had cost ge
over 50 million dollars in lost medical
equipment sales alone
when the campaign began in 1984 50 000
nuclear warheads were on constant alert
and the us was building five nuclear
bombs per day
at the close of the campaign no more
nuclear bombs were in production by
general electric
but that's not all the dark side for ge
goes deeper still
and it gets worse especially for
americans in 1986
ge purchased nbc during just one year in
general electric had received close to
two billion in military contracts
related to systems that ended up being
used in the gulf war
and of course ge are no stranger to
helping the us government with weapons
the bombs dropped to nagasaki and
hiroshima
were researched and developed with the
help of ge so
as it turned out nbc's parent company
designed manufactured and supplied parts
for every major weapon system
during the gulf war this includes the
tomahawk cruise missiles and systems for
the stealth bomber and b-52 bomber
so in reality the financial incentives
were driving the wrong way
when correspondents and paid consultants
of nbc television
praised the performance of us weapons
they were commending the equipment made
by ge
the corporation that paid their salaries
in the heat of the gulf war in 1991
retired generals and admirals became
regulars on nbc's shows during wartime
the more they told people war was needed
the less resistance the public had
towards war
this of course meant more money for ge
in the form of contracts
a share of which ended up back in the
pockets of those same generals
and this kind of thing continued 13
years later
in 2004 the company still had a big
stake in military spending
meaning that nbc's reporting of the
afghanistan war may have also been
tainted
so why do all of this well with a single
missile costing over one million dollars
to make and with tens of thousands of
missiles being fired in a conflict
you can only imagine how profitable war
can be
it really sucks that this happened but
this chapter does end on a positive note
though
in 2013 general electric sold nbc to
comcast
which of course still isn't ideal but
it's still a relief
from that conflict of interest and i'm
glad that no longer exists
so what can we make of all this well
we've learned that general electric is a
huge company
and has its hands in many fields but it
is a bit of a mixed bag
ge has done some incredible things in
their history and have innovated in many
fields
but the dark parts of their past can't
be ignored
but to end this on the plus side even
though they're still one of the us
government's biggest defense contractors
they no longer build weapons and it's
mainly just engine manufacturing that
they do in that field
so i guess that rounds out the video
thanks for watching guys don't forget to
give this a thumbs up if you liked it
subscribe if you're new definitely do
that if you want to help this channel
create more frequent videos consider
supporting cold fusion on patreon
if you want to know a bit more about
this channel how it got started
and a bit more about me and how i make
the videos on this channel hang around
for the next 10 seconds and follow the
prompts on your screen
all right cheers guys have a good one
and i'll see you again soon for the next
video
cold fusion it's new thinking